make like a baby's real mom and take it
away
trixie let's jump right in
we are coming off of a rough episode for
you I'm sure I don't know what you mean
this person left RuPaul's Drag Race not
winning the crown but definitely going
forward as a winner and creating a
career for themselves and I know they
will do that long after this because I
believe in their talent shangela looks
like you know what it's been a hard day
for you I just want to give you a hug
you know you've been very emotional then
she proceeds to psychologically play
with my mind like a cat and mouse I also
chose Chi Chi shangela did to me
psychologically you know thing with
someone walks by and they look and I was
like oh so if you are like the one
playing mind games that makes you really
suspicious that everyone else in the
competition is like planning and
plotting some of us are just trying to
survive this is how you steal the show I
can't handle another 15 second game of
Thrones monologue I'll say that much
shangela thinks it's Game of Thrones
I think it's Seinfeld just show about
nothing
yeah exactly there's a show that's a
show BB there is a theory online that
she is a mole working for the judges to
me the only mole on this season is above
Ben's lip and I think she should get it
looked at I'm exceptionally beautiful
there's a twist coming as in laganja
y'all wanted a twist without revealing
what the twist is what was your reaction
to learning what the twist was the twist
what twist all I can say about that is
RuPaul's Drag Race all-stars 3 is coming
to your TVs in 2018 did it work no but
I'll accept it you know if I say
anything close to a spoiler a red dot
will appear on my forehead and we'll
just hear RuPaul laugh from the back 40
threatening my life once again alright
there's still a lot of season left to
come yeah I know I fell on the bottom
once and I feel like everybody's like
you've really disappointed us I'm like
what's your one word to describe what is
still to come this season Oh
shocking
shocking shocking my face at the end of
this elimination when I was just staring
shocked I I mean I'm not without giving
away too much my shocked face will come
out again and again all right you have a
Funko pop I sure do and a lot I got a
lot of fans out there being like well
she obviously wins because it's her
Andrew who have Funko pops I know me
RuPaul and Alaska but what people don't
know is I started working on that Funko
pop before even got the call for
all-stars that makes people think I won
if that's a spoiler to you as long as
you buy one of them I'm happy to spoil
it for you thank you so much Trixie of
course everybody at home please watch
RuPaul's Drag Race all-stars three it's
available every Thursday at your
television or check it out on iTunes
everywhere but you don't want to do like
check it out on iTunes true fully you
know I'm gonna go in a permanent neck
brace I'm never even compelled to do
that again you ever tired the RuPaul
impression yeah it used to be fun and
then it wasn't fun as we say in the
industry winner winner chicken dinner
did RuPaul say anything to you after
that impression from the first joke she
did not think it was funny
I was like RuPaul you're such a great
host you have won ten seconds of direct
eye contact with me redeemable now and I
just stared at her and she was like okay
like it was immediate like mental
eyeball shut down like nope and I was
like great we're only here for 50 more
minutes
turns out pretending to be someone in
front of them and then not thinking it's
funny that's super fun no I told her on
the Internet it was funny
I blame y'all
[Music]